[Musique]
peu importe l'âge nous sommes tous de
près ou de loin exposés à la
désinformation sous toutes ses formes à
cet égard au fil des ans l'attention a
surtout été orientée vers la population
adulte jeunes et moins jeunes mais face
à un phénomène qui transcende toutes les
catégories sociales les enfants et les
jeunes adolescents sont parfois laissés
dans l'angle mort et si là qu'entre en
scène Élise Gravel l'auteur est
illustratrice de livres jeunesse cumule
une soixantaine de livres à son actif
dans le succès va bien au-delà de nos
frontières et dans son plus récent livre
lancé cette semaine et ben à la bordent
avec brio le thème de la désinformation
on lui a donné rendez-vous à la
librairie le gallium à Montréal
bonjour bienvenue au décrypteur j'ai
vraiment très content d'avoir entre mes
mains ici ce bouquin près de 90 pages 6
chapitres des culottes meurtrières
fausses nouvelles des informations et
théories du complot destiné un public
d'enfants comment vous est venu l'idée
quelle est l'histoire derrière ce
livre-là ce bouquin
comme pour la plupart de mes livres de
plus en plus quand il y a des sujets qui
m'inquiète particulièrement ou qui me
touchent particulièrement puis que c'est
quelque chose que j'aimerais pouvoir
expliquer aux enfants au vulgariser pour
les enfants je le fais celui-là j'ai
commencé à l'écrire quand Trump était au
pouvoir et ben la désinformation
évidemment est absolument partout j'ai
deux ados aussi et je vois à quel point
les jeunes qui sont seulement sur les
médias sociaux ne sont exposés qu'à des
informations qui proviennent des médias
sociaux et les adultes aussi en fait
mais c'est ça tout le monde et ça me
évidemment comme ça fait peur à pas mal
tout les parents de voir à quel point
les sources d'information sont biaisées
pour les enfants sont souvent aussi
orientée vers le profit puis bah je
voulais trouver une façon d'expliquer
aux enfants comment vérifier une source
d'information comment savoir si on fait
face à une fausse nouvelle à de la
désinformation et aussi comment essayer
de faire l'apport avec toutes ces
théories terrifiantes qui circulent sur
les médias sociaux constamment les
ingrédients que vous deviez avoir dans
votre besace pour parvenir à atteindre
cet objectif là mon mix préféré c'est
toujours humour et empathie l'humour ça
fonctionne toujours bien avec les
enfants puis avec tout le monde
ça se veut très drôle puis j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a des enfants qui
vont les ressort sans savoir qui sont en
train d'apprendre sur la désinformation
ils vont juste s'amuser parce que c'est
c'est plein de c'est plein de niaiseries
[Musique]
certaines personnes ajoutent même leurs
propres détails à l'histoire et si les
Scorpions c'est par nos trous des
toilettes ils vont peut-être passer nos
petits chiens oh non
[Musique]
peut-être pas des vrais scorpions c'est
probablement des Scorpions robots je me
suis toujours basée sur des vrais
fausses nouvelles ou des vraies peurs
que les gens ont des vrais idées qui
circulent puis je les ai mis juste assez
ridicule pour que les enfants rient mais
juste assez près de la réalité pour que
les enfants soient capables après de
faire ça ressemble à ce que j'ai parce
que j'ai lu dans ce livre là c'est juste
assez niaiseux pour qu'on sache que
c'est pas vrai mais à peine Donald Trump
qui apparaît là avec son histoire Donald
Trump c'est Monsieur Boutin je pense
tout de suite en tout cas la physionomie
est surtout la chevelure est assez
semblable et d'ailleurs vous recyclez un
fait réel qui concerne monsieur Trump
oui ben oui je parle de ça ça coupe de
cheveux c'est déjà loin dans l'actualité
mais le Trump avait c'était fait de
faire une coupe de cheveux à 10000
dollars puis il disait que c'était faux
que c'est des fake news quand c'était
arrivé j'avais trouvé ça très drôle puis
j'ai écrit ce livre là ça venait juste
d'arriver ça donc il y a un de mes
personnages il y a des politiciens dans
le livre aussi il y a des gens qui
veulent faire de l'argent il y a tout le
monde qui peut créer des fausses
nouvelles ou crier au fausses nouvelles
quand ça fait pas la refaire puis donne
un Trump était vraiment le personnage
j'avais même pas besoin de l'exagérer ce
personnage là il était absolument
parfait pour pour donner des exemples et
puis une des grandes vertus ou valeurs
de ce livre je trouve c'est quand vous
braquez les projecteurs sur les
mécanismes même des réseaux sociaux
inhérents aux réseaux sociaux qui font
en sorte que les fausses nouvelles quand
elle circule sur ces plateformes ça
circule pas mal les médias sociaux
bénéficient des fausses nouvelles et des
bénéficient du clic-bate et bénéficient
de des informations terrifiantes parce
que si tu vois si tu vois un Tik Tok où
est-ce que quelqu'un est en train de te
dire que tu vas tes orteils vont tomber
si tu utilises du savon parce que le
savon c'est plein de produits chimiques
un exemple de fausse nouvelle dans mon
lit et donc si tu t'entends quelqu'un
qui a l'air sérieux qui veut qui est dit
ça sur Tik Tok ben tu vas rester plus
longtemps parce que ça ça attire
l'attention ça nous fait rester là et
puis au début tu as peut-être rire mais
si tu l'entends 300 fois puisqu'il y a
plein de plein de gens qui se font
passer pour des experts sur les médias
sociaux qui ont l'air sérieux si tu
entends répéter ça par des amis après
par des vedettes par des personnes qui
te confiance mais ça risque de devenir
plus éperon puis tu vas finir par le
considérer cette idée que le savon fait
tomber les orteils mais c'est important
de parler des émotions qui sont en jeu
dans le phénomène de la désinformation
aux enfants ils peuvent à travers ça
vraiment une porte d'entrée intéressante
sur ce phénomène à mon avis c'est par
les émotions qu'on veut attraper les
gens et qu'on va les faire croire des
fausses nouvelles et c'est par les
émotions aussi qu'on va pouvoir générer
de l'empathie et de la compréhension un
phénomène à l'intérieur de nous à
l'intérieur des enfants qui fait que on
va être qu'on va aller vers les fausses
nouvelles étapes 3 garde le contrôle de
tes émotions si un titre t'effraie ou te
met en colère prend une grande
respiration avant de le partager quand
on pense avec nos émotions ce n'est pas
le meilleur moment d'agir
les dentistes mettent des micro puces
dans vos dents quoi c'est horrible et
n'oublie jamais que tu es un biais de
confirmation attends j'ai déjà un peu
peur du dentiste mais ça ne veut pas
dire que cette nouvelle est vraie je
vais faire plus de recherches sur les
dentistes avant de paniquer
ça vise un public jeune mais tout le
monde peut trouver ça hyper intéressant
et apprendre des choses en disant ça on
est tous
victimes de biais de confirmation on en
a tous un on est tous vulnérables à la
peur on est tous vulnérable à ça donc si
on commence par se dire ça puis qu'on se
dit c'est correct c'est correct c'est
pas grave ça fait pas de nous des épées
ça fait pas de nous des gens qui qui
comprennent rien on va avoir plus
d'empathie pour ceux qui pensent pas
comme nous on va pouvoir écouter mieux
puis on va pouvoir
on va pouvoir se comprendre mieux puis
on va pouvoir prendre plus de temps pour
aller vérifier ce qu'on ce qu'on entend
ce qui est très très souhaitable dans
une société polarisée comme la nôtre et
Lise gavel merci beaucoup c'est un
plaisir merci